[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
golly Miss Molly
he owns a fourth quarter
it's taking a little skate the Hornets
all-time leading scorer not taking a put
up against painting a screen Williams
Walker with the handle takes it puts it
up
[Applause]
and look at the angle then he hits it
off the glass oh wow correct his
teammates look at that JJ reddick on it
flashes him over draws contact the
concentration of Kimmel operative shoot
that ball why he's getting hit on the
waist right there and beam hits him on
the waist look still able to get it up
and in
[Applause]
Kemba Walker
[Applause]
as a flair for the dramatic
104 102
[Applause]
right shoes
[Applause]
he beats everybody to the rim lays it up
in ball game Kemba polishes it
[Music]
[Applause]
lockers
the city
[Applause]
this crowd absolutely eating it up
eleven Oh teeth points water
kockenlocker Eva
a cat burglar
that move in the paint spin draw the
contact flip it over the top
[Applause]
he's remarkable six it's Saturday night
yeah the banks are opening up town and
15 is cashing it in